yeah I don't think he said anything
wrong I think all he's doing is talking
about reality and I don't think it's
misogynistic to say you prefer a woman
that's 18 versus 25. it's literally just
a sexual preference it's the same reason
I don't think that's the misogyny but I
had this argue with my sons though when
they saw the clip the misogyny isn't
that he has a preference for girls of 18
19 25. the misogyny is in the way he
talks about every woman who's 24. as if
they're all the same and they've all
been through this Audrey background
which she finds so distasteful that's
obviously ludicrous well I think I think
he speaks with a lot of hyperbole his
goal was to go viral obviously as Esther
mentioned not all 25 year old women have
been sleeping with every single man that
they meet in the nightclub so there's
always exceptions but I just think in
general a 25 year old woman obviously
has had more experience than an 18 year
old woman and some men prefer that some
men don't like that and they think
that's completely fine I think what's
what really scares me is the censorship
that we see online on Twitter there's
actually porn on Twitter you have
terrorists on Twitter and yet a man
who's just talking about reality and the
real dynamics between them you know what
I gotta say I have to say Leia I think
you make a good point I think